je suis ravi de faire partie de cette
aventure qui avant tout humaine et puis
voilà on chantait moi c'est annick et
puis j'ai hâte de faire votre
connaissance à tous et à toutes vraiment
rien demandé accueil au plus ou moins
mythique c'est toi maintenant ça mais
pas qu'on fasse un jeu d'éveil pour se
remonter le moral est gay d'ailleurs le
strakka crois que je regarde mal et je
fais danic qui sentent le cheval va
t'aider non non vous même en tout cas
c'est magnifique tu peux me permettre
photo mentale clic par donc plus
découpée comme ça rien c'est juste un
manque de respect inouï annick
on est deuxième en format web me regarde
pas ce qu'on appelle c'est le mensonge
le vrai ennemi mais qu'est ce qu'elle à
l'appui du bricolage peut être la chef
de la nouvelle voie centrale achève de
ton cul et tu vis tu t'es pas aller au
dodo annick testud espèce de clochards
de la sorte de la province balazs mon
avis banane jeter palais ou pas dans la
merde et cool hausse légale et par là je
n'ai pas parlé c'est le spectacle avant
tu les mets ton spectacle dans ton coin
ça te plaît pardon je raccroche pauv'con
ou à la grève tu prends tes affaires et
tu te casses on a fait tous premiers à
cause de toi tu veux rester non donc tu
prends ton gros cul ton sac en jute
t'offre lambeaux tu viens ici tu te
casses nous convoque pas conduit tu veux
qu'on votre regard de la mêlée la kia
motors 1 2 3 4 sa limite et c'est vrai
avoir des bombes allaient couple on s'en
branle bas tu veux quoi un bisou aussi
allez hop tu te casses il s'aventure
s'arrête ici et maintenant dehors qu'à
toi tu prends tes fleuve était raisins
secs et tu rentres à montélimar